Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Duren Hi, welcome along to this Spiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you for listening and thank you, as ever, for being part of my world. I just wanted to use today's episode to really think about, well, the podcast really. We just turned six months old on the 24th of June. I'm speaking to you at the start of July as I record this. And so I thought it'd be a really nice chance to reflect and consider, you know, the episodes that have gone before and what it's been like for me to record those episodes and how they've been received, you know, some of the feedback that I've received. And, you know, you might be thinking, well, how many people listen to these episodes, Marianne. And I'm going to tell you, I'm going to give you a up to the minute as of 10 minutes ago, overview of how many people are listening
to each episode. And hopefully, if you've missed any episodes, this might encourage you to listen back to them as well. That would be wonderful. Right. So as you may know, the podcast recently exceeded 9,000 downloads in the six month period. As of this very minute, we're at 9,453. So I really think and hope by the time you listen to this in a few weeks time that we will have surpassed the 10,000 download mark, which is no mean feat. form that I pay for. And they contacted me to let me know that most podcasts don't get beyond 20 episodes. So to be able to be celebrating today, the release of episode 30, it feels really lovely and it feels really good that people are really enjoying the content. So, you know, to be, you know, celebrating almost 10,000 downloads in six months for an idea that I just came up with one evening when I was cooking dinner, I just literally thought, right, I could totally do a podcast for aspiring psychologists. I'm gonna, I'm just gonna get
started. I'm gonna record some episodes. Um, and I'm gonna just keep going, you know, I'm gonna motivate myself. Um, I'm gonna edit them. I'm gonna think of some stuff that I would have liked to listen to when I was an aspiring psychologist and then I'm going to see what people think. So that's what I did. And yeah, it's been really lovely hearing from you how you're slotting this into your lives and into your weekly schedules. I know that one of you likes to listen while she's at the gym in between reps. I can't believe you do that. You know, in between reps, I sit and pant. So well done to you. I'm sure you know who you are. And others of you like to go running and listen. Others of you like to listen to me before you go to bed. Um, you know, you're slotting this
into your practice and really enjoying it. Um, I know someone else who listens whilst they're on the treadmill as well. So this is good stuff, you know, and it feels like a real honor and a real privilege. Um, and as you, if you are an avid listener, you will have noticed sounds and changes in my audio over time. And I'm hoping that this current one is going to be a good fit because I've rigged up my boom arm and everything and I'm sitting in a very boring room as I speak to you. My laptop seems to be a little bit noisier than ideal today, but I'm hoping this sounds all right for you. So with no further ado, let's have a look at the stats for the episodes and what each episode has been. So the trailer was launched a couple of weeks, I think, before the main launch in December, because I wanted to get the podcast all approved, which can take a few days. It
actually took a few weeks for Apple, so that I would be ready to share it more widely, so that I would be ready to share it more widely so that as soon as it was launched, people would be able to get their hands on it. So the trailer was launched mid-December and it was just a couple of minutes. I think I probably could do with re-recording it really to make it a little bit puncture. So that might add that to my to-do list but so far the trailers had 486 downloads so thank you to each one of you who's listened to that the first ever episode which was released along with episode two and three on Christmas Eve 2021, was called Making the Most of Not That Relevant Psychology Experience. And that is the one where I talk to you about office chair Olympics and soup. But it felt like a really nice episode and people have said they found it really useful and gave them lots of ideas. That has had a whopping 719 downloads, which is really, really good.
I believe that might be our most popular episode so far. So, you know, to those 719 people, if you've not been back to listen to other episodes, why not? What did I do wrong? What were you expecting? What were you hoping for? Perhaps you didn't like the jingles, in which case maybe we're not meant to be friends. But you know, what made you stop listening? You know, I know we've all got busy lives, but what made you not click on and listen to episode two? Because could have done you know it was available that day so um if you have only listened to one um or you never even got around to to listening perhaps you subscribed and started episode one but never came back to it and now you're listening to this
episode which i think is 32 or 33 i got a bit lost um you, how could I encourage you to go back through to listen to them? So thank you for those of you who did listen and who went on to listen to episode two, which is making the most, making the most. I'm totally going to leave that in so that, you know know I'm not a complete control freak. Making the most of supervision and the supervisory relationship was episode two and that's had as of now 586 downloads which is great. Supervision is so key to so much of what we do and it's you know really part of our formative experiences it can feel like you know can feel really good it can feel really bad can make us think we're a good enough psychologist it can make us think we're great can make us think we're not very good and we should quit the profession so getting it right and being able to work through any difficulties is so important. And within that episode,
there was an option for being able to download my free supervision shaping tool. So do look out for that as well. Episode three was navigating life events as an aspiring psychologist and that was all sorts of things really grief um parenting um trauma i think we touched on um what else was that splitting up a relationship um all those kinds of things um and that has had 359 downloads so far. There's a bit of a theme coming on here, which I will highlight imminently. Keep listening, won't you? Episode four was self-compassion as an aspiring psychologist. And honestly, it key you absolutely need it i know it doesn't sound very exciting it doesn't sound very sexy but you need it and in order to get through and i don't know survive endure what's going ahead you need to welcome it into your life so
well done to the 324 people who've listened to that episode but I think that one needs to be the most popular episode really because it's so key um episode five creating opportunities for teaching training and consultation this is This is one of our most poorly listened to episodes of the original kind of set. And that's 270. But it's a really key part of the strands of being a clinical psychologist. So do listen to that one, which is episode five. Episode six, developing skills in non-invasive history taking that was a special request that was one that someone had asked me to record and that has had
299 listens so far so that's really good let's keep that going because it's a really key skill in your developing career as a psychologist, regardless of what branch of psychology you'd like to specialize in. It's a really important skill. So do take a listen to that. seven and that will run through everything you do probably in whatever sphere of psychology you get involved with as well so do take a listen to that 319 of you have done so far episode eight so date is boundary setting for yourself and your clients and that's really important stuff such as you know turning up on time and um you know making the most of the sessions and the time and um you know being honest about any difficulties and you know setting guidelines for what's acceptable to wear during a Zoom session, you know, being naked from the waist up, not cool for me. I need you to be wearing some clothes if we're doing a Zoom session, stuff like that. And 333 of you have listened to that so far. Episode nine was the first of the
ones I didn't record all in one go so I did um all of the first eight I did over a course of a few days and then get got them edited and scheduled um done all the snippets and done all the show notes it was it was like a super slick operation when I first started um and yeah nine was the first one that I'd done um you know when i knew that people were listening um and so that felt kind of cool you know when i did the first eight it was just me chatting to myself not knowing if anyone would ever listen um so um episode nine is yay you've got the job so now what and that kind of touches on imposter syndrome, really, and whether we feel like we're enough. And 325 of you have benefited from the wisdom within that.
Episode 10 is how to optimally prepare for a psychology interview. And it won't surprise you. I think that is the most um other than the trailer so far um and that is at 640 downloads um so yeah it's a good one people have found it useful they said that it was really useful so um if you've got any kind of interview coming up um within your psychology career um be that for you know relevant psychology experience or um you know voluntary honorary experience doctoral experience um a master's i don't know anything you like give that a listen episode 11 is about understanding trauma and why it matters really and why it's so prevalent in psychology to understand that and to truly have a trauma
informed service. You might listen to that episode and you'll be like, wow, she says um a lot i thought we could have an um bop challenge where people listen to it and try and count the ums and if you want to do that you know maybe we'll fling a prize in there as well let me know how many ums you can count in episode 11 of the aspiring psychologist podcast which is all about trauma 368 of you have done so far um but yeah if you want to take part in the unbop challenge listen to that one and the reason as i reflected um when i listened to it back in my kitchen i just hadn't noticed it when i edited it when i listened back to it i think it was just the really wanting to get it right. And when I spoke more recently to, to Carl, who you will meet, you'll already, already have met. I think he's episode 31. He gave me some really interesting insights into the word and
why we say it. So yeah, as you're listening to this, which I think is like episode 33, I'm going to say 32, I don't know, I'm not sure. Have a listen to the episode from Carl as well, as well as the Unbop episode about trauma, episode eight. Did I say how many people have downloaded that? I think so. 368. Yes, I did, didn't I? Okay. Episode 12 is all about resilience and whether it's always what it's cracked up to be in the world of psychology. 224 of you've listened to that, but it's an incredibly useful episode. And so I would urge the rest of you to also listen to that as well and because you know it's something that's spoken about a lot in psychology but in a way of kind of we just need to grin and bear it you just need to get through and not be broken and dented by the
process but you know it's a little bit of a rethink around that area. And it's something that people talk a lot about in the clinical psychologist collective as well. But I think that the resilience and the compassion and the life events, and then also episode 13, you know, the health and wellness goals with Ollie Matthews, 2055 episodes for that 205 downloads for that one all so my theme is the ones that will actually help nourish you not necessarily just teach you skills are the least downloaded episodes so far and actually i think those are the ones that you need the most and that will make the biggest difference to you personally and professionally. So yes, there can be a drive and a desire to learn, learn, learn and take, take, take. But we also need to be able to sit with ourselves and think about the things that we might be able to, you know, work through, improve, or draw upon the skills we've already got going on for us. And, you know, knowing that we are enough, rather than constantly feeling that urge to,
you know, to learn more, do more, more you know be more um so please do listen to the episodes um that i've highlighted but this case in in point this case in point would be do listen to the resilience episode which is episode 12 um so we've covered episode 13 which is health and wellness goals and also thinking about orthorexia and eating disorders with the lovely Olly Matthews. Episode 14 was autoethnography, what it is and how we can learn more about it and use it to talk about ourselves and our own story within psychology which is a really key part of narrative therapy, but also helps you to build your skills in reflection. So 216 of you have listened to that so far. Episode 15 is how
to optimally prepare for presentations. It is incredibly important in psychology that you're able to do that. And it doesn't always mean like a PowerPoint jobby. You know, it could just be presenting in ward round or talking about some of your research or even presenting within supervision. So we've had 217 downloads of that so far, but we absolutely could do with some more because it's a really key skill now as we're at episode 30 and we've just covered episode 15 let's pause here for a quick break and i'll be back along very soon Thank you. Right here in this book, it's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Hi, I'm Max, and I work as an assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate.
With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative and most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology, and maybe want to work in that field one day. and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look.
It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back. Thanks for listening. Hope you liked the jingle. The jingles have been such a lovely part of this podcasting experience. I love a jingle. Are they in your head? Let me know which is your favourite. So episode 16 was with the wonderful Amy Brown, who works at Swansea Uni as a fairly prolific researcher and book publisher as well. And we were thinking about getting started in research and also kind of parental mental health and infant
nutrition and you absolutely should listen to this if you haven't already because it's really useful stuff and stuff on parental mental health and kind of infant bonding is so key in the world of psychology so if you've got kind of working background into that it's going to stand you in very good stead especially if you're not yet a parent or don't plan to become a parent oh this morning walking my kids to school was stressful i was thinking i can't wait to can't wait to get on with my day because you are driving me potty um but it's kind of tricky not to say that to the kids um but we have to think about the impact of our words and how it would feel if they were in a maths lesson daydreaming to think my mummy couldn't wait to drop me off today. So I didn't say it, but I definitely thought it.
Yes. So that was that was episode 16 with Amy Brown. Episode 17 is understanding working with risk as an aspiring psychologist. And that was just little old me talking about my experiences of working with risk and understanding and, you know, talking it through and planning for safety and, you know, reducing risk as well. 258 people have listened to that one so far. And episode 18 was with Professor Graham Eorston. And we were thinking about practically managing risk, you know, skills to set up a room, and also working with the MDT as well, to really become a cohesive team and a useful and relied upon member of the team as well. We've had 270 downloads of that one so far. Please do take a listen to these episodes if you haven't because I think they're going to be super useful for you. Episode 19 was with Dr. Steve Jones and that was all about acceptance and commitment
therapy and how that might help you as an aspiring psychologist and Dr. Steve Jones is the author of Act Made Yorkshire so do check that book out as well if you haven't already. Episode 20, have I said how many people downloaded that? that 371 I can't remember if I did or not um episode 20 um was with Dr Ingram Wright and that was such a pleasure speaking with him I really had fun um learning from him what I really liked about him is that he's he really wanted to learn about me as well it wasn't just a one-way street and I really just I felt like I was in the presence of greatness with them with Ingram so do listen to that episode 298 of you have so far as well already speaking of being in the presence of greatness. I was so nervous when I recorded episode 21, which is the formulation
and the power threat meaning framework with Dr. Lucy Johnston. I just had a sense of I'm not worthy. I'm not worthy. I'm not good enough. Because she'd been such an inspiration and such a help for me in my own career as an aspiring psychologist so absolute pleasure to meet her via zoom and to you know to get get talking to her and you know produce a really useful podcast episode for you it's no surprise that 574 of you have downloaded and listened to that so far but if you haven't listened to it so far maybe the title puts you off you know maybe you're like that sounds a bit boring that sounds a bit dry i'm not really not really that interested in learning about formulation actually to that i say
you need to be it's a really key part of um of being a psychologist especially a clinical psychologist and Dr Lucy's books on this are really really worth a read as well and within that episode we talk about you know whether diagnoses are always useful and whether they can actually be harmful as well so please do listen to that one episode 22 was recorded when I realized that I hadn't got one scheduled and I couldn't really be bothered didn't really feel like being a psychologist that day and so I thought that was useful content and so it's how to be a psychologist when you're not in the mood um and it resonated with some of you because 254 of you have downloaded that but you know could be tricky when you're a talking therapist or when you work with people because sometimes we don't want to play sometimes we just want to stay in our bed and not play with anyone and not talk to anybody.
And that is part of being human. But short of having many, many sick days, there are going to be days when you're going to have to go into work when you're not in the mood. So do take a listen to that. This next one makes me a bit sad. You know, episode 23 has only had 177 listens so far. And it's about supporting someone you love if they're an aspiring psychologist or asking for support from people around you if you're the aspiring psychologist. And yeah, the theme continues, you know, the stuff that will nourish you is the least listened to. And I think that's the stuff that you most need to get through this journey. So, you know, please do listen, you know, go back to the beginning listen again go through this podcast series as it builds you know
grow with it um you know get those jingles in your head and really you know what runs through all of my episodes is compassion i want you to love what you're doing but to love yourself in the process as well it doesn't always need to be self-criticism and meanness you know so please do listen to the ones that might not seem so appealing to you because it's all so important and such useful content. So yeah, let's increase the downloads of episode 23 and get you supporting yourself and asking for more optimal support as well. So episode 24 was about power imbalances and the fiduciary relationship between the clients we help when we are healthcare professionals. That was a special request episode that's had 176 downloads so far.
I appreciate it's not a very jazzy sounding title, is it? But I couldn't really think what to call it. So yeah, if you've got any suggestions for re-editing the titles of these podcast episodes, let me know, because I know that strong podcast episode titles can be make or break. It can be whether people want to listen or give them a miss. But it's really important stuff for whatever branch of psychology you're working in and in any helping profession as well 25 was about being a parent during training and that was with not dr rose but she will be dr rose um who is a third year trainee currently um and she highlighted so many interesting and useful points about when you are a parent yourself as a psychologist, especially during training, but also how you can optimally support any parents in your cohort or
future cohort, which is really important stuff to consider in terms of, you know, being a really good cohort member, friend, colleague. So have a listen listen to that even if you don't want to become a parent yourself or if you're not a parent yet episode 26 was what i've been asked to record about whether a master's is always needed to progress your career in psychology and that was with Dr Mel West of Newman University and that's had 197 downloads so far. Episode 27 was how to approach the next application cycle if you're feeling disappointed. It's really important and we need to be able to pick ourselves up again after we've had setbacks and knockbacks that's had 217 episodes so far one of our newest episodes was the NHS working within it pre during and post training that's had 169 downloads so far in just over a week since it was downloaded. Last week's episode was on
educational psychology with the wonderful Dr. Michelle McDowell and that's had 149 downloads within the last seven days. It's really interesting and useful to listen to even if you don't want to become an educational psychologist yourself because it gives you useful and interesting information about working within schools and getting to know the different bits and pieces that happen within the education setting. And today, I speak to you on a Monday. As you know, new podcast episodes drop in on Mondays at 6am UK time. And that episode with Dr. Deborah Kingston, episode 30, has of this very minute, I just refreshed, had 41 downloads. So within a couple of hours, we've got 41 downloads. And that will absolutely continue to build throughout the day and throughout the week. But episode 30, oh, it it's such a pleasure we discussed so many things we discussed what it's like um you know being dyslexic within the
world of psychology and being diagnosed late with dyslexia um which deborah was um retraining um from um being in the military to then becoming a psychologist um A thesis wobbles when the thesis didn't work out and needed to be reset. Such useful, interesting stuff and with such compassion as well. And there's also stuff around working in forensic services and making a compassionate difference. It's just spine tingling stuff. It really was. So that is our little whip through of the 30 episodes so far um you can easily catch up on them by going to my website goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast and today I actually um installed a very whizzy podcast player on that episode so in the past I've been trying to remember to upload each episode manually but today I've managed to work out how to do the
podcast player so that all of the episodes will automatically load there so that you can grab them there or you can access them via Spotify or Amazon Music, Google, Apple Podcasts and you know I'd be remiss if I didn't say if you're listening on Apple Podcasts please if you do enjoy the content could you just take a moment to rate and review the podcast series? It will not take you a minute. All you do is find the show. I'm going to do it with you in real time. So if you go to the bottom of your podcast app, click library and then click shows. Scroll down till you see mine because you should be subscribing.
You definitely should. Click on the green one, the psychologist podcast and then in the top right corner there's like a little um dot menu and if you um so that should load the show and if you scroll down down down down down down down to um so at the moment just underneath episode 23 it says trailer if you scroll down below trailer it will say ratings and reviews um so if you could just literally click on the five stars would be amazing um that would be great um but yeah if you have an extra couple of minutes if you just scroll below click write a review and you can leave a review to let other people know why you think it's a good thing to listen to it would make such a difference and whilst we're talking about um subscribing please do go and um
subscribe to my youtube channel which is where you can also see the videos of the guests on the podcast as well. And that is Good Thinking Psychological Services. And as I speak to you right now, we've had 209 subscribers and 212 videos. So yeah, come along and subscribe to the channel because other good stuff happens on there as well. So thank you for listening to this episode.
I thought it'd be a really nice way of helping highlight any content that you might have missed. So hope you find it useful. If you've got any special requests for episodes that you'd really like to listen to, or even people that you'd like me to interview, or maybe you'd like to pitch yourself to me to be interviewed on the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, then let me know. Get in contact by going to my website, goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. And at the top there, there's an option for how to get in contact or for how to request specific episodes that you might like. So yeah, do all all those good things you'd be my new best friend um we can book ourselves an
afternoon tea somewhere that'd be marvelous um but yeah it's been really nice um recapping these last six months with you and you know you being part of my world I know I speak about that a lot but I do not take it for granted. I am thrilled that you're here and I'm thrilled that you trust me to help develop, guide, shape and nurture you. So thank you once again for being part of my world. And I will look forward to, I was going to do a Peter Kay thing then, but I didn't think I could carry it off. Yeah, like Chorley FM. I'm not going to do it. I can't bring myself to say the words. But if you know, if you've watched that, you'll know what I mean. Thank you for being part of my world. I'll look forward to catching up with you
from 6am next Monday, when you can download the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which I will level with you. I am just about to record now. And then I'm going to do lunch with Marianne for my people in the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And then I'm actually going to have some lunch myself. I think I'll have some hummus and some rice cakes and some brie and some salad and maybe even some port saloo as well because port saloo rules um maybe a bit of ham um like a nice little polish kind of coleslaw thing which i'm'm slightly addicted to. Tomatoes, a bit of lettuce. Yeah, that's what I'm going to do. So yeah, I hope that's made you hungry. If it's breakfast time, it might not have done. It might be like, oh dear, too early for thinking about hummus.
But yeah, that's my slightly oversharing about my lunch. I think I'm hungry. I think I'm hungry. On that note note take care of yourself i'll catch up with you very soon with dr marianne jernan my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner i read the clinical psychologistologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there, and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.